Weegee Wagner on Twitter he asked a good
question is res evil 7 a good place to
start for newcomers to this series I
will start answering that I think it is
I think you know this is where it gets
tough to not spoil things whether it
fits in the traditional resin evil
storyline we can kind of talk about that
in general terms but this game is such a
different experience than any other
resident evils in some ways in a lot of
ways it's very much you know a return to
form we keep saying right the survival
the items the fact that it's very like
kind of a consolidated setting that
you're gonna learn from playing spending
more time in it it's also more like
atmospheric and tone and like dreadful
like you were saying but I think this is
removed from the storyline of the
franchise enough that you could come
into this and have it might not make you
like appreciate the story of the earlier
games because it's nowhere near as just
convoluted and weird and melodramatic
which I love about the older games but I
think res evil 7 is a great starting
point it's a good way to it's weird
because if you play this and then go
back to the other game it's gonna feel
like two separate series except for like
a few Easter eggs but of course like if
you know the series well you're gonna
see like certain design tropes that have
made their way over in a good way I
don't know Scott what do you think could
you would you recommend someone that's
never played resonable game I'm gonna
answer this in a really like diplomatic
non-answer kind of way come on so here's
here's my response diplomatics yeah here
we go here it is here it is I don't
think that you need to have played older
Resident Evil games in order to enjoy
Resident Evil 7 right if you have never
played as an evil you can play as an
evil 7 and you will enjoy it basically
as much as somebody who has played
Resident Evil okay that's my response
okay cuz I don't want to spoil story
stuff right yeah Pete you're about an
hour and a half in so so well what's
gotten away in one bowl yeah all sorts
of the minions I put on the cheers and a
person milk what else do you would you
what do you having for lunch I don't
know tussles nix hairs you walk
eh and I was thinking like more like his
kids let's call back to the kid I'll be
back later hon I have to feed the swamp
goblin and his litter he's tracking
today it's a weird anthropological
Eureka's rolling in his chair you have
to end water and mud to the dam good
answer Peter really like gotta cuff your
breakfast for a marker we should
probably actually into the question I
think you say it makes a pretty good
point like the fact this game really
does not try to like make a huge deal
about being part of the Resident Evil
universe means that you don't really
need to have those connections to the
Past and this sort of modern horror as
you're describing the last segment also
makes sense so it's it really is a fresh
start like it feels like something that
is both resident evil but it doesn't
need to be Resident Evil yeah I think a
lot of people that have played more
recent horror games which at least first
person aside from alien isolation have
been on the indie scene right it's
amnesia there's more so yeah yeah and I
think I think obviously like again to
plug it one more time and are reviving
resin evil seers they have an entire
episode the first episode is about how
the decline of Resident Evil and Silent
Hill the flagship horror series led to
this increase in horror from indie
developers who could take more creative
chances because they didn't have the
risk involved the overhead and the
actual like triple-a money like budgets
involved but I also really like that I
think resin evil 7 takes what made those
indie games good and I'm just using
indie as a broad term they're not all
indie games so you have like outlast to
commit red barrel is very that's an
indie developer if I'm not mistaken I
mean they're technically independent in
that they are not owned by a larger
parent company that term gets indie is
just like but I think not triple-a I
think res evil 7 takes what made those
non Triple A horror games great and also
combines it with what made Resident Evil
originally great in a way that I think
this is the best introduction to a
resonable series I think if someone has
not played Resident Evil up till this
point as much as remake and resin will -
are two of my favorite games in any
genre I don't think I would recommend
those first I think you'll have a deeper
appreciation of those if you can see how
it works in the modern day first
I'd also set you up to not like those
games though because they are
restrictive they're receptive and like
you were saying it's pretty campy it's
pretty yeah it requires a lot like
esoteric like knowledge of characters
and events and if you're playing remake
that's when they were introduced
what was the characters know I know but
I'm saying by and large though it's the
cameras is the cam penis that will make
people be like what this is you were
almost a Jill sandwich I think it will
at least show you that these kind of
things can work oh yeah did you see it
did you hear um we Tim Tory and I from
Capcom played resin evil yesterday on a
live stream and he was using your
account because you had the saves that
we want to start from and he kept
getting a bunch of bronze trophy some
like you're racking up the bronze trophy
from your Brown set Tim's like oh ah
Peter bronze is pretty good Pete bronze
reviews editor at games behind I need a
tan up to that moniker Pete bronze more
like Pete saran wrap Pete self-tanner
Pete self-tanner Brown I'm transparent
we have a very pasty crew on the lobby
thankfully this table is white so
hopefully the contrast makes us look
less pale in comparison or it reflects
up at us and makes me look even milkier
it's definitely possible milky is a
disgusting way to end someone's skin
don't want moist and milky when we break
this video out into bleeding that please
do milky stubble at least it's not like
you look very marshmallow eat today you
kind of do I always do bronze I think if
this would I personally think this would
be a good introduction to the series I
don't know if you're gonna like love
remake going back to it but I think
it'll show you how those kind of design
tenets can work in a modern-day horror
games I think in that credit can serve
you you can bind our mats yes it's my
job here yes so Luigi Wagner thank you
for the question we were considering
doing a segment on that and yeah we're
glad you tweet it in at me so that's the
end I'm gonna plug a few more things
before we end off the res Neal segment
again reviving Resident Evil the
two-part series that someone who sane
worked on go watch the behind the scenes
documentary it's very good Scott's
review is up on gamespot 8 out of 10
you really like the game a lot about
what's did I do Pete's liking it so far
we have guides going up on antique coins
the bobble heads the new game+ items we
have a lot of that stuff going up we
have VR which we just talked about if
you're just joining the show or if
you're watching this on youtube or
GameSpot as a broken out video place
game VR it's a great game it's for all
intense purposes it feels like Capcom is
back with resin evil and let's hope they
continue this they've kind of hinted
that this is gonna be another you know
that the structure of they do three
games like this three games like this
three games like this not counting
spin-offs so let's hope like you know
theoretically a resin evil eight and
nine kind of can build on the success
that this inevitably will carry over in
the post-launch weeks
[Music]